today we are gonna overclock these 10
216 mini leds and get the performance
that they're actually capable of hey
guys it is max ever since apple released
the 6k xdr display and then the macbooks
one thing that i have really wish for is
the capability to actually use them
outside of hdr environments these
screens can reach up to a thousand six
hundred nits and a thousand it's
sustained full brightness at all times
across the screen which is absolutely
incredible but outside of hdr video or
hdr editing the screens are locked at
the same 500 nits as all of the previous
macbooks for many years meaning that in
most situations you are not getting any
extra brightness compared to what you
get you know with your previous lcd
displays and that is a bummer now apple
does have really good
anti-reflectivity coatings on their
macbooks compared to other windows
laptops we've shown that off
but there are still situations where
you're in a really bright room or if
you're outside and you're using your
macbook and you're maxing out the
brightness but the screen still cannot
uh fight against any glare and
reflections this is where vivid comes in
and is going to allow you to access the
full capabilities and pretty much
overclock it or unlock your display now
overclocking in general is where you
increase the performance of you know a
chip that you have it's capable of more
but it's locked down in software which
is exactly what apple is doing now i'm
going to show you how this works the
differences and also talk about any
downsides any risks
and basically answer some of the
questions that you guys may have now
this creator of this application he's
been working on this for a long time
ever since these macbooks came out he
has wanted the ability to access the
full brightness and he's finally been
able to make this happen and it's not
some weird hack it's actually using
apple's own api to enable this so it
should keep working now he also has some
other really cool applications like
bluetooth where when you close your
macbook it'll automatically turn off the
bluetooth and open it when you open it
it turns it on again
things like forehead to hind the notch
and the round corner some really cool
things that he wanted to see with uh
apple products and he made it happen now
i have the full version that i purchased
but you can also download the trial and
i have to say it's really cool how it
actually gives you this little uh
tutorial as you are adjusting oh my
goodness right there
right out of the gate god that is bright
look at that so that's our normal
brightness right right around there
and that top camera is probably being
blown out on the left-hand side and this
is just our desktop all right well let's
activate this bam and now let's see what
it could do and let's go through all of
the options and then answer your
questions so as you saw you still use
your regular brightness keys to adjust
brightness here i am turning the
brightness all the way up it looks
plenty bright in this room of course
it's not outside and they just hit a
little higher and guess what at this
time that you want it brighter it
actually goes higher we see the second
menu bar and now it's just going into
hdr mode and oh my goodness
this is getting bright this is
i don't know it's incredible to see a
screen this bright a lot of windows
laptops are like 300 nits with poor
anti-reflectivity this is a thousand
that i'm looking at right now wow i've
never seen google
look this bright it is crazy let me turn
down that brightness here guys because i
don't think you guys are seeing any of
this because of just how bright that is
this is gonna be amazing for the
outdoors all right let me go ahead and
look at the options here we can disable
vivid and you can actually use that
shortcut as well uh you can have it
launch automatically that's about it and
we have split screen so let's enable
split screen
oh
no i can't that is crazy i mean that
looks like an insane difference that's
because it actually is this is your 500
nits this is your 1000 nits this looks
like 200 right now just because my eyes
got used to
this much higher brightness but that is
just an insane difference and that
allows you to test out the app if you
want to see it for yourself now right
now it's raining outside hopefully i'll
get some b-roll shots once it stops
comparing our other 16-inch base macbook
pro with standard settings as well as
this one with vivid enabled so you guys
can see those differences that is crazy
now let's talk about the downsides well
the first downside is
battery life when you are maxing out
your brightness this much and you have
this difference you're definitely going
to be sucking more power actually let's
go ahead and test that out i have this
really amazing power bank called the
charge that was sent out to us you guys
can check them out on kickstarter or
their website that actually tells you
all of your info over here it is
absolutely amazing so i will go ahead
and plug in the usb type c and this can
output actually 100 watts
and
let's go ahead and plug this in
and i will go ahead and hit disable
vivid and it looks like we're pulling
about 55 watts and now let's go ahead
and kick up the brightness all the way
and now we're pulling 58.83
watts so not that much more power but of
course if you're doing applications that
sit power with the apple silicon chips
and allow it to get you know insane
battery life well that's gonna increase
it by quite a bit and if you're doing
things like video editing that sucks
power anyways then you might not notice
as big of a difference now what are the
other things that people are worrying
about well since we see this insane
brightness difference here uh well
people are worrying what if you mess up
your display
well
you actually cannot mess it up because
apple has certain protections enabled
they say up to 1600 nits
but if it gets too hot it will actually
limit that so there are protections in
place apple designed the whole screen to
be able to run at 1000 nits sustained
full-time unless there's something else
that comes up so this screen can handle
that and once again vivid does not use a
low-level display hack to push your
display to get super bright using
apple's apis which allow it to function
properly and this is why it's taken this
long to create this now some people are
also concerned about any extra resources
being pulled that will drain your
battery and vivid is upfront about this
they actually say that it uses roughly
two percent of your cpu and then also
about 40 megabytes of memory so the
overhead is not high at all and i don't
know what they're going off of you know
maybe the lowest level least powerful
macbook and then the overhead is
actually less percentage wise for the
higher ones and then about color
accuracy this is where you guys have to
be careful if you guys watch our
comparisons to windows laptops with
those especially the oleds if you adjust
your brightness above what you actually
calibrated at your color accuracy goes
out the window the same thing goes uh
with this display now the macbook
displays are a lot better but still 500
nits is where they are calibrated at so
if you are going to be maxing out the
brightness your colors will shift a bit
now not by a huge amount because when
you're watching hdr videos apple doesn't
want them to look you know funky and way
off uh but you have to keep that in mind
so there you guys go i was super excited
to see this application i'm not going to
be using it all the time but in those
situations where reflectivity is an
issue especially when i'm outside trying
to use my laptop my kids are playing at
the park this is going to be incredible
go ahead and check it out this is not a
sponsored video at all they did not
reach out to us i just really liked uh
what they were able to do so if you guys
want to test it out for yourself you can
download the trials test out the split
screen and let me know what you guys
think thank you guys for watching this
ben max check out one of those great
videos over there click that circle
above to help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers we would really
appreciate it and we will see you in the
next video
[Music]